This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great, as always, to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s.
There is no pain, I think, more unique and inexplainable than the pain of unrecipricated and unrequited love. It feels very misplicated. it feels like a lot of people don't really understand what we're saying or what we're trying to communicate when we say, I love this person so deeply and they don't love me back and I don't know how to move on. It is such a bizarre state to be in. We're so used to heartbreak coming from a mutual affection or the pain of loving someone only occurring when they loved you back. But honestly, I think that it's just as easy to be perhaps in love, obsessed, overwhelmed by your feelings
with someone, even though they are completely one-sided. And in all honesty, I think it can really drive us a bit mad. It can drive us to become someone that we never thought we'd be. It can drive us into a completely strange and confused mental state, not really knowing where to turn. But we do actually have a word for this feeling, as confusing as it may be for you right now, as chaotic as it may be, what you're feeling is limerence, this involuntary or consuming sense of love and obsession with somebody who doesn't feel the same way about us. It's this attachment that we can't let go of and it impacts us in so many ways and it impacts so many of us, but we, I think, just feel a little bit ashamed to talk about it.
mainly because it feels so much like love for us, but we kind of know that from the outside or to a stranger or a friend, it wouldn't look that way. Maybe we think that we'd be called dramatic or that we're overreacting, we're too sensitive, we're romanticizing things too much, whatever it is, we feel like there is no place for this feeling that it's not a valid one to have.
But I really do think that it is. I think that it is actually a lot more normal than you would think, and that there is a lot of valid explanations as to why we feel this, why so many of us find ourselves in this state. Let's bring that all out into the open today and really discuss what causes us to enter into the space of limerence. I have my own stories of limerence that will hopefully bring you some comfort as well. You know, when I was 21 I spent about, I honestly would have to say almost two years, maybe a year and a half, madly in love with someone who was very clear he did not feel the same way. And even after I kind of recovered from that, that continued into my
mid-20s where I would meet people, new people, and immediately romanticize a very grand future together after the first date. And even after the fifth, sixth, seventh date, when it became clear that they were not thinking the same thing, I just couldn't let it go. And I don't like to use the word crazy, but it did feel like I was slowly going crazy. Like, this is not a normal response. The more that I've paid attention and learned about the evidence behind this, the studies, the psychology behind it, the more I realized that actually this was something that was driven by a much deeper need, a much deeper sensation, and a much deeper explanation.
and now that I'm in this like very healthy, happy relationship, I can kind of find a balance between, I wouldn't want to say like calm and healthy love, but sustainable reciprocal love and this like all-consuming passion. So let's talk about it today. I know it may be uncomfortable at times, but I do think that that innate and intense capacity to love is something very beautiful and something that we can find a space for. We're going to break down exactly what limerence is when it was first given a name, the four stages of limerence. I don't know if you know what those are, but also why it is that some of us just feel more intensely than others. What gets us stuck in the cycle? And finally, how we can slowly find a pathway out of the state, how we can move on from unrequited love,
even if that idea feels quite painful right now, even if you feel like you are relying on this person and this emotional state as a crutch, I promise that there is closure to be had, there is hope to be had, and hopefully this episode brings that to you. So I'm very excited, passionate about this subject actually, as a fellow person who has been in a limerent state more than I can probably count, there is a lot to discuss. And hopefully you learn something. Hopefully you heal. something. Without further ado, let us get into the psychology of limerence. Even if you've never heard of the term limerence before, you've probably experienced the sensation or seen someone else experience it and just not really had the label.
Limerance at face value may be seen as a kind of unrequited love where we feel intensely about someone who does not reciprocate. It is a lot more than that though. For the people who are experiencing it, it is a deep and sometimes intrusive obsession with this person. And it feels so, so similar to passionate love, maybe even mutual love. But it has this melancholic undertone that you know this person doesn't feel the same way. You know this is not someone you can hold onto who will return the feelings. And yet despite that knowledge, there is not much that you feel is in your power that you can do to move on. You may have tried many, many things. None of it has really worked. So the term was created by
the psychologist Dorothy Tenov in 1979. So kind of actually a lot further back than you might expect. Dorothy is actually a really fascinating woman because she spent a great deal of her life, basically wanting to understand love, the different kinds of love we experience, how love differs between us, the science behind love, desire, compassion, passion, all of those things. And it was through that kind of scientific exploration and work that she started interviewing people for her second book, which was very appropriately titled Love and Limerance. And she interviewed over 500 people on the topic of love. She got their testimonials, she had them answer, you know, questionnaires, surveys.
And from this extensive data, what she saw was that. that there was the typical kind of love that we would expect called amarance, where people are kind of equally in love with each other, they're set on building a life together, it's, you know, very reciprocal. And then she also identified this state of limerence, which she hadn't really, you know, nobody had really given it a label before. It was this combination of infatuation, love sickness, passionate love and what very much felt like romantic love to the people experiencing it, it just wasn't fulfilled. Actually, most researchers would actually say that limerence has a lot in common with passionate love.
And we should note that, you know, the word passion initially meant agony, which kind of goes to show that there is a lot of agony in this situation. There is both a beauty and a pain kind of intertwined with the state of longing and love. love. In fact, actually, there was further research on this kind of emotional experience, which seems to determine that the very unattainable nature of our goal of being with this person is actually what makes the state of limerance so powerful, the fact that we know deep down that we can't have it. That is one explanation. And there's also the other explanation that because we are given occasional positive reinforcement, you know, someone looks at you from across
And we should note that, you know, the word passion initially meant agony, which kind of goes to show that there is a lot of agony in this situation. There is both a beauty and a pain kind of intertwined with the state of longing and love. love. In fact, actually, there was further research on this kind of emotional experience, which seems to determine that the very unattainable nature of our goal of being with this person is actually what makes the state of limerence so powerful, the fact that we know deep down that we can't have it. That is one explanation. And there's also the other explanation that because we are given occasional positive reinforcement, you know, someone looks at you from across
the room, they text you back. Every now and again, you get to see them occasionally. That positive reinforcement actually keeps the hope of your affection alive. You think that it might eventually be realized. To further see this kind of inaction, this state of longing that seems to contribute to itself, that seems to grow on itself based on occasional positive reinforcement, we also need to explain the four stages of limerance, which are attraction, obsession, elation and frustration, and finally resolution, which is not so much as a stage, I guess, but where we exit the cycle, where we finally heal or move on, which is very much possible. I want to make sure that that is very clear and articulated. It is very much possible to move on from limerence.
the room, they text you back. Every now and again, you get to see them occasionally. That positive reinforcement actually keeps the hope of your affection alive. You think that it might eventually be realized. To further see this kind of inaction, this state of longing that seems to contribute to itself, that seems to grow on itself based on occasional positive reinforcement, we also need to explain the four stages of limerence, which are attraction, obsession, elation and frustration, and finally resolution, which is not so much as a stage, I guess, but where we exit the cycle, where we finally heal or move on, which is very much possible. I want to make sure that that is very clear and articulated. It is very much possible to move on from limerence.
Let's talk through these stages, though. So attraction is when that kind of intoxicating spark first connects you to. Maybe it's a first date where you felt an instant bond or particularly deep conversation, something that is emotionally connected you in a way that makes you see potential and really fall for this person. It feels, again, very similar to falling in love. The euphoria, the adrenaline, constantly thinking about this person. And what that leads to is obsession. Your thoughts become consumed with this person at work, at school, when you're driving, when you're with your friends, when you're zoning out. You're always kind of in this fantasy scenario or rethinking something that has occurred. You bring them up in conversation as often as possible.
You're thinking about all the ways that you could potentially see them this weekend. Their kind of words and actions are also constantly being analyzed for signs of interest or rejection. You know, did they text you back a little bit quicker today? Did they linger? Was that song on their Instagram story about you? Did they talk to you a little bit differently? Your mood suddenly becomes heavily dependent on their perceived reactions to you. This is when we kind of get to the state of elation and frustration, otherwise known as kind of the emotional roller coaster stage, which may be all familiar to some of you. You kind of of alternate between feeling infatuated and validated to exhausted and hopeless. It's been likened
in this way to kind of an emotional drug addiction that is insatiable and uncontrollable. You have these crushing lows followed by these hugely euphoric highs and you start to feel more desperate for those highs but also more distressed when you don't receive them, which I think is basically your mind starting to pick up on the fact that this is a state of longing, this is an inconsistent relationship, this is an inconsistent bond, and it doesn't really know where to place that. It doesn't really know what to do with it because the pursuit, the chase, feels so addictive. And sometimes that state of elation and frustration, that state of longing can last up to, you know, three years.
that was one of the, like, one of the figures that really shocked me from this initial research was how sometimes it even outlasts love. Our state of limerance can outlast the love that occurs in a relationship. But what we really and seriously need to start steering towards when we get to that state, three years of not much, of nothing, of wishful thinking, that's when we really need to start seeing a resolution. Either, you know, I'm going to say the least likely possibility here, and I know it might be upsetting, but either, you know, a mutual relationship does eventuate, which I do think is unlikely, or we do start to see, you know, our link and our bond to them gradually fade. Our brain basically is like, okay, we need to find a way through this. We cannot
that was one of the, like, one of the figures that really shocked me from this initial research was how sometimes it even outlasts love. Our state of limerence can outlast the love that occurs in a relationship. But what we really and seriously need to start steering towards when we get to that state, three years of not much, of nothing, of wishful thinking, that's when we really need to start seeing a resolution. Either, you know, I'm going to say the least likely possibility here, and I know it might be upsetting, but either, you know, a mutual relationship does eventuate, which I do think is unlikely, or we do start to see, you know, our link and our bond to them gradually fade. Our brain basically is like, okay, we need to find a way through this. We cannot
stay in this state for the next three, six, nine, 12 years. It gets bored of it. It gets bored of it gets bored of longing. Basically, no matter what happens, we cannot stay in a perpetual state of longing for that long. Eventually, and hopefully this brings some hope and positivity here, we do kind of realize that we deserve more. We do kind of want to put our attention towards someone who is going to reciprocate our affection, our adoration and our time.
Something will trigger you to move on. I remember this very clearly what this was for me when I was in a limerent state a few years back. And I'd spent, you know, months basically like begging some universal, higher power to like, please, please let me move on. Please let me see some clarity in this situation. Please let me be more logical about this. And I was genuinely desperate. And what actually ended up helping me was I saw this person.
again. I hadn't seen them in, you know, a while, probably over a year. And upon finally seeing them, I was just kind of like, oh my gosh, you are not what I expected you to be. You are not who I wanted you to be. I built up this whole fantasy and I think it's ready that I, you know, give myself what I deserve and I try and process this. And it did take a few more months, but it was one of those things where once I had the opportunity to leave the situation and come back into it and see that it really wasn't a connection, it wasn't anything more than infatuation and an obsession on my behalf. I was like, okay, I have permission now to realize that this is never going to eventuate and it's time to move on. There are a few other things to note about limerence, but, you know, beyond just the four stages.
Limerence is at its core involuntary. you cannot make or force yourself into a limerent obsessive infatuated state. It's almost like there is some underlying pull towards this person, how you're feeling. And some would suggest that that's actually a result of how dopamine and serotonin circuits are wired in the brains of those who experience limerence more often. Limerence has been related to addiction. And we know this from a series of studies conducted. by the anthropologist, Helen Fisher.
And Helen Fisher, she actually passed away last month, which is quite sad. I hope she's enjoying whatever event, you know, awaits us in death. Because, you know, she was a pretty remarkable lady. She was one of the first people to prove that love and with that limerance is hardwired into the brain. Her and her co-authors basically drew on brain scan evidence that showed that romantic love is, you know, associated with dopamine. which is associated with certain addictive,
I don't know if it's addictive cycles, but addictive underlying systems in the brain. And love can be a positive addiction when it is required. And it's a negative addiction when it's unrequited or inappropriate. And that kind of explains why, you know, when you are in a state of limerence, you are experiencing a negative addiction. you're experiencing something, you know, deeper than your conscious awareness of, like a full dopamine system that is working against you to keep you attached to this person.
The second thing to note is that Limerent sometimes does blind us to faults or flaws of the person that we desire. And there was another series of studies conducted in 1999 in which the main researcher found that the dominating similarity between people, experiencing limerence was that no matter how hard they tried, they just could not point out anything that made this person unattractive, even when it was pointed out to them, even when it had to do with what this person was making them feel. Like, surely this person isn't all that great considering you're pretty hung up on them and pretty upset and distressed and almost in agony. And they would say, well, no, no, no, that's not them. It's just, you know, the circumstances. We have this blind loyalty to their greatness, which is a very hard illusion to break.
And the final thing that I think is important to note about limerence, it is normally based more on an emotional desire rather than a sexual desire, which is really what distinguishes it from lust. If you are in a state of limerance, you'll probably relate to wanting to just simply hear from this person, to connect with them, to talk for hours, to see where your relationship could grow rather than just wanting them to be attracted to you or just wanting to have sex with them. It's what really puts it more in the realm of romantic love for me. You care the way you would care for a romantic partner or someone that you've known for a lot longer
and that's what makes it very mentally and emotionally complicated. And, you know, if you've never experienced this, it can be really hard to understand. You know, how could you continue to be so intensely into someone, obsessed with them, when they have no interest in you. You know, they have no interest in being with you. Surely that's illogical. And yet, it's not. And yet it makes a lot of sense and it happens to a lot of us.
They are able to shape your daily mood, your actions, your thoughts, your feelings. And there's this big underlying question of why. Why? Why is this happening? And I have a few explanations for you. Limerence is really a mixture of biological, psychological, psychological, emotional and environmental factors. but above all else, it is just mental activity. It is not a sign from above that you're meant to be together,
that you shouldn't quit on them, don't give up. Your obsession and infatuation is not hinting at destiny. It is basically an interpretation of events rather than the events themselves because basically your brain is trying to find a way to make this work. It's holding on to the fixation because of the slimmest chance of possibility that it perceives rather than if there is actually possibility to be had. We, of course, already know about the neurological and biological kind of origins or causes, some would say, you know, the relational patterns that mimic and create addiction.
The other significant factor is our attachment style. And we hear a lot about this, so I will keep it kind of short and simple. But our early ways of learning how to bond with another human, usually our parent, is going to go on to influence our behaviours around bonding with others as an adult, both platonically and romantically. if that childhood relationship you had was somewhat disturbed or what we would call disorganized, you may continue to seek out that same pattern of attachment and relationship later on, later on when you're pursuing a romantic interest.
Perhaps you're looking for someone, you're constantly, you know, very attracted to people who are hot and cold with you, who are unreliable because you are seeking to finally have a situation where you can change them, where you can make someone love you. If you are quite anxious, this can also lead to that same fear of rejection and obsessive behaviours that is very characteristic of limerence where you tolerate the mixed signals or you let it feel your desire to be closer to them because you don't want to face the alternative, which is a life without them. And that really exacerbates a lot of the clinginess, a lot of those intrusive thoughts. It may also come down to a subconscious avoidance or emotional and unavoidance.
availability on your behalf, which you might not expect. You might think that the person who is not reciprocating is the one who is emotionally unavoidant. But for people with an insecure attachment style, being in love with someone who won't return those feelings actually means that they can stay in a distant relationship without making any other real connection. You know, loving someone and being loved in return, it does require a lot of vulnerability. And you have to accept that this is two-sided, that there is risk and reward that actually you could be hurt. Love, inherent in love, is a possibility of hurt. But when you stay stuck on unreclided love or in a limerent state,
this allows you to kind of remain in the safety of a pseudo-relationship that can never be real, that will never require you to be truly vulnerable, that, you know, the biggest risk is that you fall out of love with this person, without ever actually, you know, experiencing the true depth of love, and you don't actually have to commit to them. So what this one author says is that actually maybe limerence is protecting us from having to be, I don't know, attached or fall in love with someone who will reciprocate and who will force us to finally accept and be in the presence of healthy love. This is obviously a huge general assessment, and I will say it's not true for everyone. There are a lot of people who experience limerence but have experienced healthy love just as much. Like we mentioned before,
you know, it's very different for each of us and it's also not something that you can sign up for. So there are unconscious mechanisms at play that drive you into those specific situations and an insecure attachment style may be one of them. It may also be more common or more likely that you are someone with a very real vivid sense of fantasy, imagination. you're very romantic, sentimental. You dream so big about the potential or the life you have with someone that it just feels like that is very much something that could come true, that it's not a hypothetical anymore.
You can feel the Sunday mornings that you wake up together and cook breakfast. You can picture your future children. You can smell that vacation in Fiji that you're going to go on. Like it's very, very vivid for you. The future that you have with them is very vivid. And it's that imagination that really gets you hooked, that gets you invested. There is this potential. And since you can imagine it, surely there is a reality where it could be real.
If only they thought like you. If only they could see this like you, then you guys could be something. The final explanation that is so important for me to mention here also comes down to ADHD because ADHD and limerence, I don't know if you could say they mix very well or not well at all, but either way, they are very much intertwined. If you think about limerence and ADHD, they have quite a few things in common, right? Hyperfocus, rejection sensitivity, emotional dysregulation when it comes to this person. Limerance is also essentially a hyperfixation that can only heighten those obsessive.
and recurrent patterns of thinking. I thought this person's description to an online magazine called Attitude. It's a quarterly journal on advancements and articles to do with ADHD. Really worth checking out if that's something you struggle with. But I thought that this person's description
was really just the best way we could describe it based on her lived experience. Falling in love is immediately all-consuming for me. My hyper-focus and fixation are insane. I lose hours, days, weeks and months to my obsession. And then at some point, the dopamine runs out and my fixation lifts. I realize the person I've been obsessed with is just that, a person, and I withdraw. When the magic of dopamine is lost, seeing the other person clearly is often crushingly
disappointing. Disappointing because there's no way they or anyone could ever be the permanent dopamine high am constantly seeking and disappointing because once again I've completely lost myself to this obsession. I will say this thing of no one could ever be the permanent dopamine high. I get that and I do really, really, I think, empathize with that feeling that, you know, you cannot be in that constant state of obsession and love for your entire life. But there is something uniquely more beautiful about a love that is calm and about a love that does not always have to make you excited because it is just a constant. often excitement and anxiety are very interlocked. So we start to confuse them. And I do think that
the older you get, the more you realize that there's a lot of things that can bring you happiness and dopamine and love is definitely one of them. But above all else, sorry, we really want it to bring us serenity and peace, like I said before. Here is what another person had to say about this, about the interactions between ADHD and limerence. My crushes occupy a large portion of my thoughts and they make it hard for me to concentrate. I've even experienced falling in love with someone I didn't even like. It is like getting on a bus from which I can never disembark. And that analogy, I think, what she just said is spot on.
She said it so perfectly. It's a ride that once you get on, involuntarily get on, you feel like you can't get off. And the emotional consequences of that can be really, really quite scary and quite profound, frustrating at times. You feel, of course, deep emotional turmoil, excitement and joy that suddenly turns into despair and longing. And you kind of feel pushed and pulled between those two states constantly. So there is never a balance, there is never a steady state that lasts for that long. Then there is the low self-esteem because your feelings haven't been reciprocated. And you begin to
think that reflects something about you when it doesn't. It truly doesn't. It just comes down to what this person wants. And that's something that you can't control. You continue to have value whether they want a relationship or not, you continue to have value despite what happens to that connection. There can also be a degree of isolation as well, not wanting to share what we're experiencing with others because we feel embarrassed to admit, you know, that we're so caught up in this situation. And people who don't experience limerence, I think, just don't quite understand the intensity. They don't quite understand the wishful thinking, how you, you know, eventually you do want to get over this. You are tired of being in the state, but it's not as simple.
That's not how your brain operates is, you know, being like, okay, I'm ready to move on and then you move on. I don't know if anyone can possibly do that. Eventually though, and this is the good news, you do get to a place of kind of exhaustion, of wanting it to be over. And I think that is when the path out starts to become a bit more clear. When we are, I think truly at our lowest with the situation is when we start to see hope. It is possible to recover from limerance to one day be in a place where their name doesn't make you jolt, doesn't give me those adrenaline spikes. You're not waiting for the text back. That is very, very possible. And I want to talk about some of the steps we can take to do that, to realize this after this short break.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是
percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击了小金的胸部吗？还是坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。什么？乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅谈 80 年代的快克（可卡因）。坦白说，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只要大家想知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿其中的主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field
我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康月，我将结合我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于陷入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。但我们仍在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变得只剩下输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
这是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeart Radio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
发现自己卷入了一起亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。由此开始了长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，以及迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I asked you guys all over on Instagram, what do you want to know about limerence? The number one thing you asked me was, how do I intentionally move on? How can I stop limerence from influencing a relationship in the beginning? How can I bring this under my control? You know, there were stories from you all about how you've been miserable for months, even years,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当我通过 Instagram 问大家，你们想了解关于痴恋（limerence）的什么内容时？你们问我的最多的一点是：我该如何刻意地走出来？我如何才能阻止痴恋在初期影响一段关系？我如何才能将这种状态控制住？你知道，你们分享了许多故事，讲述了你们如何痛苦了几个月甚至几年，
sometimes over short relationships, crushes, people you've only met a few times. Again, it wasn't a choice for you. your brain has obviously seen some possibility in them that it's gotten attached to and it's gotten attached to that chase, that roller coaster that does bring a lot of dopamine, but we do want to bring our limerent states back into our control as much as possible. So we can see ourselves clearly, see the person we admire clearly, the relationship clearly, and then hopefully see other opportunities and other options for us. If you want to know first off whether there is a basis for your limerance or not, or maybe a better way of saying this, whether what you're experiencing is
有时仅仅是因为短暂的关系、迷恋，或者只见过几次面的人。再次强调，这对你来说不是一种选择。你的大脑显然在他们身上看到了一些可能性，从而对他们产生了依恋，并且迷恋上了那种追逐的过程、那种会带来大量多巴胺的过山车般的感觉。但我们的确希望尽可能地将我们的痴恋状态重新掌控在手中。这样我们就能清晰地看清自己，清晰地看清我们钦佩的那个人，清晰地看清这段关系，然后满怀希望地看到属于我们的其他机会和选择。如果你想首先弄清楚你的痴恋是否有基础，或者换一种更好的说法，弄清楚你所经历的是
love or amortes. Firstly, do a quick evaluation of the relationship. Is there commitment? Is there a label? Are they reciprocating? Is there a sense of continuity such that in two weeks, things aren't going to drastically change? You can rely on them. You know that they can rely on you, that they care about you.
爱情还是痴恋。首先，对这段关系做一个快速评估。是否存在承诺？是否存在名分？他们是否有回应？是否存在一种连续性，使得两周后情况不会发生剧烈变化？你可以依靠他们。你知道他们可以依靠你，他们关心你。
I think in that instance, maybe, especially in the beginning, this is a sign of of mutual affection that is growing into a relationship. If it is the opposite of that, that is when we know that perhaps what we're entering into is limerence. If you feel like you can't really trust your evaluation, like even though you know it's limerance, you are still fully invested, really forcibly override your desire to be in close contact with them. Override your desire to reach out, to check in, take a few big steps back. And I know it sounds simple. I know it's advice that is often given, but you need to go no contact. It is the tried and tested best strategy,
我认为在这种情况下，也许尤其是在初期，这是相互吸引并正在发展成为一段关系的迹象。如果情况恰恰相反，那我们就知道，我们可能正陷入痴恋之中。如果你觉得自己无法真正信任自己的评估，比如尽管你知道这是痴恋，但你仍然完全投入，那就真正强行压制住与他们保持密切接触的渴望。压制住你想要联系他们、关注他们的冲动，往后退几大步。我知道这听起来很简单。我知道这是经常给出的建议，但你需要彻底断联。这是经过时间和实践检验的最佳策略，
even if at times it requires superhuman strength and discipline and sacrifice. Sometimes it does require sacrifice. But what you've got to do it for is not for yourself right now, but for your future self. Your self in six months, who's going to be six months further into the healing process, rather than just starting out, thank you to you. Thanks to your current self who is taking on the burden and the pain
即使有时这需要超人的力量、纪律和牺牲。有时它确实需要牺牲。但你必须这样做的原因，不是为了现在的自己，而是为了未来的自己。是为了六个月后的自己，那个已经在疗愈过程中前进了六个月的自己，而不是才刚刚开始，感谢现在的自己。感谢你现在的自己承担起了提前开始的
of starting sooner. Schedule in a one month period of time, even two weeks if you want to start small, where your contact is super minimal. And notice whether the emotional roller coaster begins to slow a little bit, begins to take fewer leaps. Chase that feeling, the feeling of peace, serenity, control over what you're experiencing. I think that first week or period of withdrawing from your love interest, it's going to be quite revealing because, like, like we've said, it's like a withdrawal from a drug source, which is how I think a lot of people would explain it. In the immediate period afterwards, everything will suddenly get perhaps more intense because all that dopamine you feel in response to small messages or interactions with
沉重负担和痛苦。安排一个为期一个月的时间段，如果你想从小事做起，甚至可以是两周，在这期间你们的联系降到最低。并注意情感的过山车是否开始放缓，是否开始减少剧烈的起伏。去追寻那种感觉——平静、安宁、对自己所经历的事情的掌控感。我认为在疏远你倾慕对象的第一周或那段时间里，会相当具有启发性，因为正如我们所说，这就像是戒除毒瘾，我想这也是很多人会用来解释这种感觉的方式。在接下来的紧接着的一段时间里，一切可能会突然变得更加强烈，因为你因收到那个人发来的微小信息或互动而产生的所有多巴胺都在消退。
that person are fading. They're less accessible to you. And then eventually you'll feel like a bit of balance is restored and it won't come all of once, but it will be one day at a time. it's also during that period where we want to practice what I like to call replacement therapy. You know, we can do that for substances like nicotine. We can also do it for limerence. There are a couple of, I would say, compulsions that go hand in hand with limerence. So social media checking, finding ways to run into them or hang out with them, even at the expense of your own plans. This is what we would call proximity seeking behavior.
他们对你来说不再那么容易触及了。然后最终你会觉得恢复了一点平衡，这不会一下子全部实现，但会一天一天地好起来。也正是在这段时期，我们想要练习我喜欢称之为替代疗法的策略。你知道，我们可以对尼古丁等物质这样做。我们也可以对痴恋这样做。我想有几种强迫行为是与痴恋如影随形的。比如查看社交媒体，寻找偶遇或和他们厮混的机会，甚至不惜牺牲你自己的计划。这就是我们所说的寻求亲密行为。
Repetitive thinking, getting stuck in daydreaming or fantasy. and what we want to do is have a substitute for those behaviors because all of them are continuing to, you know, exaggerate this cycle, continuing to keep you in this cycle of limerence. So a substitute could be a mindful distraction. You could literally doodle, you could do five push-ups, you could listen to a meditation, you could go for a walk and leave your phone at home when you feel the desire to reach out. Even better are activities with friends where they can be the sole source of our attention. we can pour our love into them, and it will be reciprocated. There is something about platonic friendship, you know, laughter, shared time, that can be the best distraction from our intrusive reflections or affections,
重复思考，陷入白日梦或幻想中。而我们想要做的是为这些行为找到一个替代方案，因为所有这些行为都在不断地，你知道的，夸大这个循环，不断地让你陷入这个痴恋的循环中。所以替代方案可以是有意识的分心。你可以随手涂鸦，你可以做五个俯卧撑，你可以听一段冥想，当你感到想要联系对方的冲动时，你可以去散步并把手机留在家里。更好的是和朋友一起进行的活动，他们可以成为我们注意力的唯一来源，
and it can really also stop us from self-isolating, from withdrawing, which only really contributes to our state of longing, because the only thing we can think about is this person. When you build up your other relationships and you invest in them, I think your limerence starts to feel smaller and less important amongst these constant giants of love, which is friendship, family, connection. It's also really important to create things to look forward to with your friends that don't place this person at the center of your universe. And that may also involve finding space from the situation that you combine with those wholesome activities with friends.
我们可以将我们的爱倾注在他们身上，并且会得到回应。柏拉图式的友谊、欢笑、共度的时光有一种魔力，它能成为转移我们那些挥之不去的反思或爱意的最佳干扰，它确实也能阻止我们自我孤立、自我退缩，而自我孤立和退缩只会加剧我们的渴望状态，因为我们满脑子想的都是这个人。当你建立起其他的关系并投入其中时，我认为你的痴恋开始变得渺小，在爱、友情、家庭和连接这些永恒的巨头面前显得不那么重要。创造一些和朋友一起期待的事情也非常重要，不要把这个人作为你宇宙的中心。这可能还包括从你与朋友进行的那些健康活动所结合的处境中抽离出一些空间。
You know, book an Airbnb for a weekend trip with your friends. one with a pool, one with a big backyard, maybe near a beach, and just make memories that revolve around the people who are constants in your life, who you adore, who are consistent, and most importantly, who reciprocate. This is also really important at the beginning of a relationship. You know, if you're someone who feels like limerence always bulldozes every opportunity you have to get to know someone slowly and purposefully, like you just feel the need to rush in, you can actually create deliberate time blocks for yourself, you know, speed bumps almost, activities that you have planned in advance, events where, you know, they're not going to be there
你知道的，和朋友们预订一个周末旅行的爱彼迎（Airbnb）。找一个带泳池的、有一个大后院的，或者靠近海滩的，去创造那些围绕着你生活中那些恒久不变的人的记忆，他们是你崇拜的、始终如一的，最重要的是，会给予你回应的人。这在一段关系的初期也非常重要。你知道，如果你觉得痴恋总是摧毁你所有慢慢、有目的地去了解一个人的机会，就像你总是觉得需要急于求成一样，你其实可以为自己创建刻意的时间隔离块，
so that you get a break from them, from the intensive thoughts, from the drive to see them be with them constantly. The other big way to bring limerence back into your control is to really be quite bossy and direct with your irrational thoughts. So the irrational thoughts that often accompany limerents are things like, they are the one for me, I can't be happy without them, or they will eventually feel the same way. If I just try harder, they will realize that we're destined for each other. You know, they're perfect. I'm the one who's not good enough. This is true love, and if it's over, I'll never recover. I'll never find anyone better. These thoughts sound really believable when they're coming from us, when we're the ones thinking them, because of course we trust our
几乎就像是减速带一样，提前计划好的活动，你知道他们不会出席的活动，这样你就能从他们身上抽身出来，从那些密集的思绪中抽身出来，从想要不断见到他们、和他们在一起的冲动中解脱出来。将痴恋重新掌控回自己手中的另一个重大方法，就是对你的非理性想法表现得专横和直接一些。因此，通常伴随痴恋而来的非理性想法有：他是我的真命天子/真命天女，没有他/她我无法快乐，或者他/只要我再努力一点，他/她最终会有同感。如果我再努力一点，他/她就会意识到我们是天生的一对。你知道的，他们太完美了。不够好的是我自己。这就是真爱，如果结束了，我将永远无法恢复。我永远找不到比他/她更好的人了。当这些想法从我们内心发出时，当我们是思考这些想法的人时，它们听起来非常可信，因为我们当然信任自己的
own judgments and intuitions. But you have to remember just because you think something doesn't make it real. A lot of the time, those thoughts are based off fear, faulty information, false expectations, and that is what is contributing to this limerent state. Don't let these thoughts steer the ship, interrogate them when they come up. I'll use the example of, they're the only one for me, I can't be happy without them. That's a common one. This thought is often what keeps us solely focused on this one person, even when better people come along. But if we replace that thought with, there are many other people out there who would love me, and probably better than this, this is not the only person who completes me, love is a union, love is a collaboration, I deserve this to be reciprocated.
判断力和直觉。但你必须记住，仅仅因为你有某种想法并不代表它是真实的。很多时候，这些想法是基于恐惧、错误的信息、错误的期望，而这正是导致这种痴恋状态的原因。不要让这些想法掌舵，当它们出现时，去审讯它们。我举个例子：“他是我的唯一，没有他我无法快乐。”这是一个很常见的想法。这种想法往往让我们只专注于这一个人，即使有更好的人出现也是如此。但如果我们用这样的想法来取代它：“外面还有很多人会爱我，可能比这个人更好，这不是唯一一个让我完整的人，爱是结合，爱是合作，我值得得到回应。”
Then we start to slowly, I think, wake up to the fact that we deserve more. The same goes for a belief like, if I just try harder, soon they'll realize that I'm meant to be with them, that we're destined to be together. What I want you to really replace that thought with is, you know, would true love really make you work this hard? Would true love really require you to prove yourself? Would it be this much of a struggle? You know, I don't know about you, but I don't hear many love stories from people who were kept on the bench for years. I don't hear many love stories from people who, you know, for half a decade were not given the love and compassion they deserve, only for someone to change their mind and suddenly they have this flourishing relationship. I'm sure it does happen occasionally,
然后我们开始慢慢地，我认为，意识到我们值得拥有更多。对于这种信念也是如此：“如果我再努力一点，他们很快就会意识到我是注定要和他在一起的，我们是天生一对。”我真正希望你用来取代这种想法的是：真正的爱真的会让你付出这么大的努力吗？真正的爱真的需要你去证明自己吗？它会是一场如此艰难的挣扎吗？你知道，我不知道你怎么想，但在冷板凳上坐了多年的人的故事里，我听不到多少爱情故事。在那些长达半个世纪的时间里没有得到应有的爱和同情，却突然有人改变了主意，然后就拥有了繁荣关系的那些人的故事里，我听不到多少爱情故事。我确信这种情况偶尔会发生，
but if you've ever seen the movie, he's just not that into you. There's this line in the movie that says, you've got to remember that you are the rule, not the exception. Don't let the promise of being the exception keep you in the same place for months or years. We could also benefit from practicing some psychological deprogramming or reprogramming that takes this love interest off the pedestal. One useful tactic to kind of trick your brain into devaluing this individual is to focus on what you don't find desirable, even if you have to force yourself to search for it. You know, when you are in the company of this person, focus on either things that are a floor. Fixate on the floors instead. The basic goal, I know it sounds kind of mean, but the basic goal is to basically counter your brain's
但如果你看过电影《其实你不懂他的心》。电影里有这样一句台词：你必须记住，你是规则，而不是例外。不要让成为特例的承诺让你在同一个地方停留几个月或几年。我们还可以通过练习一些心理反向编程或重新编程来受益，把这个倾慕对象从神坛上拉下来。一种巧妙地诱骗你的大脑贬低这个人的有用策略是，关注你认为不可取的地方，即使你必须强迫自己去寻找它。你知道，当你和这个人在一起时，要么关注那些有缺陷的地方。转而执着于缺点。基本的基准，我知道这听起来有点刻薄，但基本的基准基本上是通过向大脑提供负面数据，
attempts to idealize this person by feeding it negative data instead. You can also focus not just on their visible qualities, but also your own internal response to them. Sometimes we want to avoid thinking about the shame, we want to avoid the guilt, the sting of rejection, the hopelessness, but do the opposite. Tune into it. Make sure you can name what's caused it. It's this person. It's your perception of them. It's your relationship with them. Sometimes the only way out, it is is truly through. You have to explore these emotions as uncomfortable and dark as they may be to finally get to the resolution stage. My final tip is to find closure in any way possible. And the best way to do this is to seek closure from your person by mustering every sliver
来反击大脑将这个人理想化的企图。你不仅可以关注他们看得见的品质，还可以关注你对他们的内在反应。有时我们想避免去想羞耻感，我们想避免内疚、被拒绝的刺痛、绝望，但要反其道而行之。去调动它。确保你能说出是什么造成了这种情况。是这个人。是你对他们的感知。是你与他们的关系。有时唯一的出路，就是真正地穿越它。你必须探索这些情绪，无论它们多么令人不安和阴暗，才能最终到达解决阶段。我的最后一个建议是，以任何可能的方式找到释怀（closure）。而做到这一点的最好方法是，鼓起你所有的信心和勇气，向你心仪的人寻求一个结果，问他们：这会不会成为我以为的那种关系？你对我有兴趣吗？你以后会对我有兴趣吗？
inch drop of confidence and courage you have and asking them, is this ever going to be what I think it could be. Are you interested in me? Will you ever be interested in me? This is definitely the final nuclear option and it might seem catastrophic, but I think that sometimes it's necessary. And this specific site that talks about living with limerence, they put it really, really well. Yes, we don't want to do that because we think we may ruin a beautiful friendship. But be honest with yourself. Is it actually that beautiful or it's even a friendship or is it causing you more pain than it's worth and after you've been honest with yourself be honest with them if you know they feel the same way about you then you've got you've got what you wanted and that's the closure if they don't if there is any uncertainty on their end
这绝对是终极的核选项，它可能看起来具有毁灭性，但我认为有时这是必要的。而那个专门讨论如何带着痴恋生活的网站，他们说得真的非常好。是的，我们不想这样做，因为我们认为可能会毁掉一段美好的友谊。但对自己诚实一点。这真的是那么美好的友谊吗？还是它给你带来的痛苦远超它本身的价值？在你对自己诚实之后，对他们诚实。如果你知道他们对你的感觉是一样的，那么你就得到了你想要的，这就是一个结果。如果他们不是，如果他们那端有任何不确定性，
I think that we suddenly get a bit of a reality hit we get a bit of reality exposure and we realize that you know, it is time for us to gift ourselves the possibility, or give ourselves the idea that someone else could love us more. That is like a real gift to be like, actually no, I'm deserving of a mutual love, of a brilliant love, of a generous love. This is maybe not the situation that I deserve. And that's really how I want to conclude this episode by showing you that there are, there are many paths out of this.
我认为我们突然受到了一点现实的打击，我们接受了一点现实的洗礼，我们意识到，你知道，是时候把这种可能性当作礼物送给自己了，或者给自己这样一个观念：另一个人可能会更爱我们。这就像是一份真正的礼物，心里想：其实不对，我值得一份相互的爱、一份灿烂的爱、一份慷慨的爱。这或许不是我应得的处境。这确实是我想要结束这集节目的方式，向大家展示出，其实，有许多条路可以走出这种状态。
The only thing promised, you know, in life it is change. and this also applies to limerance. When we're in it, it feels like it's never going to go away. But then in three years' time, you look back at this very moment and you realize how far you've come, how much you've done, how beautiful it was to mature out of that state, to find a love that is healthy and fulfilling, which you most certainly will find. And I know that you're probably suffering right now. I've been there.
生活中唯一承诺的事，你知道的，就是变化。而这也适用于痴恋。当我们身处其中时，它感觉永远不会消失。但三年后，你回过头来看此时此刻，你会意识到自己已经走了多远，你已经做了多少，从那种状态中成熟出来是多么美好，去寻找一份健康且充实的爱——你肯定会找到的。我知道你现在可能正在受苦。我也经历过。
I've done that. I got the T-shirt. It was a slow journey out of it. But now in the stage that I'm at. that I'm almost grateful that I got the opportunity to see that I could love that deeply, that that was a real kind of superpower, a real talent, skill, characteristic of mine. And, you know, just because they couldn't feel it, just because they didn't want it, they were giving me my love back, doesn't mean that it was worthless.
我经历过这一切。我穿过那件T恤（意为“我对此深有体会”）。走出来是一段缓慢的旅程。但现在在我所处的阶段，我几乎很感激我有机会看到自己能够爱得那么深，那是一种真正的超能力，是我真正的一种天赋、技能和特质。而且，你知道的，仅仅因为他们感受不到，仅仅因为他们不想要，他们把我的爱退了回来，并不意味着它毫无价值。
And actually, there are many people who would feel very, very lucky to be loved the way that you love. So consider it. I hate the word superpower, because it feels, So like almost cringe, but consider it an asset. Consider it something that makes you absolutely wonderful. And it means that when the right person comes along, you're going to have everything you need to love them deeply and for that love to be sustained.
事实上，有很多人会觉得自己非常非常幸运，能被你这样的人爱着。所以考虑一下吧。我讨厌“超能力”这个词，因为它感觉太老套、太尴尬了，但把它当作一种资产来考虑吧。把它当作让你变得无比美妙的事物。这意味着当对的人出现时，你将拥有一切所需，去深深地爱他们，并且让这种爱得以维系。
So thank you so much for listening to this episode. I really hope that you enjoyed it. I hope you learned something. If there's someone in your life who needs to hear it, make sure you send them a link. And I really hope you're taking care of yourself that you felt some comfort from this because I want you to know you're not alone. Sometimes that is the greatest comfort.
非常感谢大家收听本集节目。我真心希望你们喜欢。我希望你们学到了一些东西。如果你们生活中有人需要听听这个，请务必把链接发给他们。我真的希望你们能照顾好自己，并从中获得一些安慰，因为我想让你们知道，你们并不孤单。有时，这才是最大的安慰。
If you again enjoy the episode, leave a five-star review. Make sure you're following along for more upcoming episodes. And if you have something to say about this topic, this episode, any other topic or episode, or even a suggestion, a follow-up, a query, please feel free to DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Until next week, stay safe, stay kind, and be gentle with yourselves. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
如果你再次喜欢这一集，请留下五星好评。确保关注以获取更多即将播出的剧集。如果你对这个话题、这一集、任何其他话题或剧集有什么想说的，甚至是建议、后续追踪或疑问，请随时在 Instagram 上私信我：That Psychology Podcast。直到下周，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。2% —— 在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the Irish. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的“2%”。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
对1979年来说，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
这是疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过
the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。真人制作，品质保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。